as i mentioned to you offline like
somebody i admired um some of you know
andre capathy i think the two of you
different trajectories in life but
approach problems similarly in that he
codes stuff from scratch up all the time
and
i he's created a bunch of little things
outside of
uh even outside the course
at stanford
that have been tremendously useful to
build up intuition about stuff but also
to help people and uh they're all in the
realm of ai
um
do you see yourself potentially doing
things like this or built you know not
necessarily solving a gigantic problem
but on the journey on the path to that
building up intuitions
and
sharing code or ideas or systems
that
give inklings of agi but also kind of
very useful to people in some way so
yeah first of all andre is awesome i
learned a lot when i was going through
my larval phase from his blog posts and
his stanford course and you know super
valuable i got to meet him first a
couple years ago when i was first kind
of starting off on my gentleman
scientist bit
and just uh just a couple months ago
when he went out on his sabbatical he
stopped by in dallas and we talked for a
while and i'm i had a great time with
him and then when i heard he actually
left tesla i did of course along with a
hundred other people say hey if you ever
want to work with me uh it would be an
honor yeah so i'm he thinks that he's
gonna be doing this educational work but
i think someone's gonna make him an
offer he can't refuse
before he gets too far along on it oh
his his current interest is educational
i was like yeah
um
he's a special mind yeah is there
something you could speak to what makes
him so special
something you understand like he did
he was very much a programmers
programmer that was doing machine
learning work rather than it's a
different feel than an academic where
you can see it in paper sometimes where
somebody that's really a mathematician
or a statistician at heart and they're
they're doing something with machine
learning but i you know andre is about
getting something done and you could see
it in like all of his earliest
approaches to it's like okay here's how
reinforcement learning works here's how
recurrent neural networks work here's
how
transformers work here's how i you know
crypto works
and i am and yeah it's just
he's a hackers you know one of his old
posts was like a hacker's guide to
machine learning yeah and you know he
deprecated that and said don't really
pay attention to what's in here but it's
that thought that uh that carries
through in a lot of it where it is that
back again to that hacker mentality and
the hacker ethic with what he's doing
and in sharing all of it yeah and a lot
of his approach to a new thing
like like you said larva stage is let me
code up the simplest possible thing
to build up intuition about it yeah like
i say i i sketch with structs and things
when i'm just thinking about a problem
i'm thinking in some degree of code
you